And this is like a whole new field of agentic engineering. And, you know, people have been doing programming languages for a long time. It's a lot more matured. And I feel like there's a lot more to learn and discover here in the world of agentic engineering. And like how agentic engineering impacts our programming languages, our compilers, our tooling. Like that I'm very interested in. You know, I don't have answers yet for how agentic engineering impacts programming languages. I think I'm starting to see how it will impact, you know, tools, compilers, et cetera.
而这就像是智能工程（agentic engineering）全新的一页。你知道的，人们研究编程语言已经很久了，它成熟得多。我觉得在智能工程的世界里，还有很多东西需要我们去学习和探索。比如，智能工程将如何影响我们的编程语言、编译器和工具链。我对这些非常感兴趣。你知道的，对于智能工程将如何影响编程语言，我目前还没有答案。我想我开始看到它将如何影响工具、编译器等等。
But I don't yet know how it impacts programming languages. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast, episode 292 recorded on June 10, 2006. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host, Bryce, we chat about GPU mode. Are programming languages still important? Post-AGI, Wingspan, lawn care, and more. Well, so I think the biggest, a colleague said to me the other day regarding out of research that like 90% of your effort should go into preventing cheating and reward hacking. And I think that's more or less right. You know, back in the day, there was this tool called C Reduce before AI.
但我还不知道它将如何影响编程语言。欢迎收听 ADSP 播客，我是 Connor，今天和我的联合主持人 Bryce 一起，我们聊聊 GPU 模式、后 AGI 时代的编程语言是否依然重要、展翅翱翔（Wingspan）、草坪护理等话题。嗯，所以我觉得最重要的一点——一位同事前几天对我说，关于自动研究，你90%的精力应该放在防止作弊和奖励骇客（reward hacking）上。我觉得这个说法大体上是对的。你知道的，在过去，在人工智能出现之前，有一个叫做 C Reduce 的工具。
And C Reduce is this thing where you'd give it like C source and then you'd give it a test. And you'd use it for like reducing a compiler error. Like let's say that you had like an internal computer. compiler error that you hit with some, you know, code base with GCC. And so you would, you would, like, create a pre-processed header of that, like, or you'd create a pre-processed source file of from the code base. It'd be like 500,000 lines of code. And you'd give it to C-Reduce. And then what C-Reduce would do is it would go in and it would apply a bunch of these code transformations, like, you know, like remove all the comments and, like, you know, try removing, you know, this function and then this function and try renaming variables, etc.
C Reduce 是这样一个工具：你给它一段 C 语言源码，再给它一个测试用例。你可以用它来简化编译器错误。比方说，你在某个代码库中用 GCC 遇到了一个内部编译器错误。因此，你会从代码库中创建一个预处理后的头文件，或者创建一个预处理后的源文件。代码行数可能高达 50 万行，然后你把它交给 C-Reduce。接下来 C-Reduce 会做的是，它会进去应用一堆代码转换，比如移除所有的注释，尝试移除这个函数然后那个函数，尝试重命名变量等等。
trying to minimize the reproducer of your error message. And the biggest challenge with writing good C-reducers is the test script. So if you gave it a crappy test script, like, you know, you give it a test script, you're like, okay, just like, you know, the way that you test whether it still reproduces is just run GCC on this file and then like grep for the error message. Okay, well, if you do that, then it's going to give you back something that'll reproduce your error message. But there will be a dozen other error messages, too. And the rest of the code will be ill-formed. And so it's like, okay, so what we really want is that this is a valid reduction, a valid minimization if the code continues to produce the error message with GCC, but it also
努力将你的错误信息复现代码缩减到最小。编写好的 C-reducers（C减缩工具）最大的挑战在于测试脚本。所以如果你给它一个糟糕的测试脚本，比如你给它一个测试脚本，心想：“好吧，测试它是否还能复现的方法很简单，只需在这个文件上运行 GCC，然后用 grep 查找错误信息。”好吧，如果你那样做，它确实会给你返回一个能够复现错误信息的代码。但同时也会冒出十几个其他的错误信息。而且其余的代码也将是不规范的。所以这就成了：“好吧，我们真正想要的是，如果代码继续通过 GCC 产生错误信息，同时它还能……”
compiles fine with cling. And then like, okay, then now it will only give you a minimizer where the code is valid C++, but it happens to break with GCC. And then there were like other things where like if you were, if you did something subtly the wrong way and like a reducer, like it would just reduce your source file down to like being like an empty file. And it's like, hey, this, this passes your test. It passes your test. So, you know, this is a valid reduction. And so like whenever I would run into a compiler error, I would go and like carefully craft this test script to test whether the bugs still reproduced. And then I would just like put it into C-Reduce and wait a few hours.
用 Clang 正常编译，那么这就是一个有效的简化，一个有效的最小化。然后，好吧，现在它只会给你一个精简版，其中的代码是合法的 C++，但偏偏在 GCC 上会报错。然后还有其他情况，如果你在减缩器中以微妙的错误方式做了一些事情，它就会直接把你的源文件缩减成一个空文件。然后它会说：“嘿，这个通过了你的测试。它通过了你的测试。所以，这是一个有效的精简。”因此，每当我遇到编译器错误时，我就会去精心编写这个测试脚本，来测试 Bug 是否仍然可以复现。然后我就会把它放进 C-Reduce 里，等待几个小时。
And it's the same thing with AI. It's the same exact process with AI that the, in particular with these auto-researchentic, you know, loop sort of workloads. Ours is more what you and I are doing is truly more of what I would call auto-research, which is something where it is iteratively following some form of a scientific process where it's trying something, then testing whether that's whether it works, then evaluating a metric, and then deciding whether to keep it or revert it. But anyways, the biggest and most important thing is the quality of your tests and your validation,
AI 也是如此。与 AI 的过程完全一样，特别是对于这类“自动研究智能（auto-researchentic）”的循环工作负载。我们的做法——你和我在做的——更确切地说是可以称为“自动研究”的东西，它会以某种形式迭代地遵循科学流程：尝试某事，测试它是否可行，评估指标，然后决定是保留它还是回退。无论如何，最大也是最重要的事情是你的测试和验证的质量，
because if there are exploitable holes, it will go after those. And in particular, if you're doing something like optimization or, you know, even if it's not optimization, even if it's not performance, if it's just like correctness, like, if you're testing for like three cases and there's like some other cases that your test don't cover, like, yeah, it's going to write code for those three cases. It's not going to care about the other cases. It's going to break stuff for the other cases. And yeah, it's a challenging art and science. I wish I could say more, but I don't think I can talk too much more about the techniques. Only matter of time. Only matter of time.
因为如果有可利用的漏洞，它就会钻空子。特别是如果你在做优化之类的东西，或者，即使不是优化，甚至不是性能，哪怕只是正确性——比如，如果你测试了三种情况，而还有一些你的测试没有覆盖到的情况，那么是的，它会为那三种情况编写代码。它根本不在乎其他情况。它会把其他情况下的代码弄坏。是的，这是一门具有挑战性的艺术与科学。我希望我能多说一点，但我觉得我不能透露太多关于这些技术的事。只是时间问题。只是时间问题。
Should we try and talk about some non-AI stuff for 30 minutes? What do you think? Is there stuff that we... How's the... How's the kid coming along? The kid's good. Do we know a boy or girl? Yeah, it's a boy.
我们要不要试着聊 30 分钟跟人工智能无关的话题？你觉得呢？有没有什么我们……那个……小孩怎么样了？小孩挺好的。知道是男孩还是女孩吗？对，是个男孩。
Do we have names yet? We have a couple contenders. You know, I have a top name. Shema has a top name. I think both are... I think if she convinced Shima to just let the Internet decide from the set of top names. No, no, that's never going to happen.
起好名字了吗？我们有几个候选。你知道的，我有一个首选名字。Shima 也有一个首选名字。我觉得两者都……我想如果她能说服 Shima 让互联网从这些候选名字里挑选一个……不，不，那绝对是不可能的。
And, yeah, baby's good. I'm in the middle of reading. I'm on my third parenting book and see how many I get through in the next two and a half months. I'd say probably I'll stop at like somewhere between 10 and 15. Not that that's necessary, but, you know,
然后，是的，宝宝很好。我正在阅读中。我正在读第三本育儿书，看看在接下来的两个半月里我能读完多少本。我觉得我可能会在 10 到 15 本之间停下来。倒不是说这有多大必要，不过，你知道的，
it doesn't take me too long to crush audiobooks. And I'm learning a lot, folks. There's a lot of academic literature out there about how, to raise a baby. Olivia, who we both know and who was at NVIDIA for a long time, when our other buddy, J.F, was about to have his first kid. I was at the Sipas was committee meeting in Ulu, which was 2016.
听完有声书对我来说花不了多长时间。而且我学到了很多，各位。外面有很多关于如何抚养婴儿的学术文献。我们俩都认识的 Olivia 曾在英伟达工作了很长时间，当时我们的另一个好朋友 J.F. 正准备迎来他的第一个孩子。我当时在乌卢（Ulu）参加 SiPaS 委员会会议，那是 2016 年。
That was my first international trip, my second committee meeting. So I'd met Olivier and J.F. at the previous meeting, and we had to quickly become quickest thieves. And so we're at, we're in Ulu in the middle of, you know, the sort of middle part of Finland. And JF's talking about, you know, like, becoming a father soon. And Olivier tells him, like, listen, we can talk about parenting philosophy now. But as soon as you have a kid, it will become impossible for us to talk about it.
那是我的第一次国际旅行，也是我的第二次委员会会议。所以在上次会议上我就认识了 Olivier 和 J.F.，我们很快就成了亲密的朋友。所以我们在乌卢，在芬兰中部的一个地方。J.F. 在谈论关于不久后要当父亲的事。Olivier 告诉他：“听着，我们现在可以谈论育儿哲学。但一旦你有了孩子，我们就再也无法讨论这个话题了。”
Because once you have a kid, you develop your own, like, very deeply held beliefs about what's the correct way to parent. And there's like no point in us talking about it after that, because you'll have your worldview I'll have my worldview, and they may not align. All right. Well, stay tuned to whether or not that turns out to be true for me. I mean, I don't think that's really going to be the case. I always think that, like, if you're the kind of person that's worried, if you're, well, it probably doesn't apply all the time, but if you're worried, like, oh, am I being a good parent, blah, blah, blah, that art.
因为一旦你有了孩子，你就会对什么是正确的育儿方式产生自己非常坚定的信念。在那之后我们再讨论就没有任何意义了，因为你会有你的世界观，我会有我的世界观，而它们可能并不一致。好吧。那就拭目以待，看看对我和对其他人来说，这是否会成为现实。我的意思是，我不认为事情真的会这样。我总是觉得，如果你是那种会担心的人，如果你——嗯，这可能不适用于所有情况，但如果你在担心，比如“哦，我是一个好父母吗，巴拉巴拉”，那么艺术……
Hey, we just took. What? It's just one sort. Wow, that's actually, it one. One sort by a good bit. Nice. Okay. All right.
嘿，我们刚拿下了。什么？只是排序（sort）。哇，那其实，它拿下了。凭借排序第一名领先了不少。不错。好的。好吧。
So out of GPU mode leaderboard, I'm now the number one for sort, vector sum, prefix sum, histogram, gray scale, number two for convolution. And I haven't tried Matt Mueller vector ed yet. I'm sorry, you were saying things. Yeah, yeah. On the B200, there's multiple GPUs. No, no, no. Look at the H-100.
所以在 GPU 模式排行榜上，我现在是排序、向量求和（vector sum）、前缀和（prefix sum）、直方图（histogram）、灰度图（grayscale）的第一名，卷积（convolution）的第二名。我还没尝试矩阵乘法向量加（Matmul vector add）呢。不好意思，你刚才在说什么。对，对。在 B200 上，有多个 GPU。不，不，不。看 H-100。
I think I've already taken more slots on H-100 and on a number. L4. And interestingly... The sort you don't have it. Not H100. I don't think I've done sort on H100 yet. Like histogram, I'm pretty sure I now have all of them on histogram, which is the one I started with.
我想我已经比在 L4 上拿下更多 H-100 的榜单了。有趣的是……那个排序你还没有。不是 H100。我想我还没在 H100 上做过排序。比如直方图，我很确信我现在在直方图上拿下了所有名次，正是我最开始做的那一个。
Yeah, I have all of them on histogram. It's a shame that you didn't choose a shorter username, like B. Lelback, because on mobile, it cuts off the gold emoji. Yeah. So the interesting thing, on the GPU mode, there's different, you know, leaderboards for each GPU type. and initially I did not instruct the model to only submit to the GPU type that it had locally. So all of my agents run on GPU nodes so that they can do local testing and evaluation.
对，我在直方图上拿下了所有名次。真遗憾你没有选一个短一点的用户名，比如 B. Lelback，因为在手机上，它把金色表情符号给截断了。是的。所以有趣的是，在 GPU mode 上，每种 GPU 类型都有不同的排行榜。最初我并没有指示模型只能提交到它本地拥有的 GPU 类型。所以我的所有代理都在 GPU 节点上运行，这样它们就可以进行本地测试和评估。
And what happened is, you know, the models love to quit, you know, when the going gets tough, they love to give up. But they've got this directive to never quit. And so like once it feels like, well, I can't really make any more progress on an L4 GPU, it would start to take. taking its kernel for L4 and just submitting it to the other GPU types and would like get wins there. So I thought that was pretty funny. I have not run on A100 yet. I'm saving the A100 slots for a particular setup that will use Nemotron. And I want to be able to evaluate how well it does before I have all of the slots.
结果就是，你知道的，当事情变得艰难时，模型最喜欢摆烂，它们最喜欢放弃。但它们收到了“永不放弃”的指令。所以当它觉得“好吧，我在 L4 GPU 上实在无法取得更多进展了”时，它就会开始把针对 L4 的 kernel 拿来，直接提交到其他 GPU 类型上去，然后在那上面赢得名次。所以我觉得这挺逗的。我还没在 A100 上运行过。我把 A100 的名额留给一个将使用 Nemotron 的特定设置。我希望在占满所有名额之前，能评估一下它的表现如何。
The only reason I haven't gone after Matmole and Vectarad is I don't think that they're particularly interesting problems. because the speed of light answer is going to be pretty clear for both of them. But I don't know. Maybe I'll be wrong on that. Oh, man, I'm very happy with that sort result. Because that one, that sort one, was running with Deep Seek V4. And so that's the first time that I've gotten really good results out of Deep Seek V4 Pro. I'm very happy with that. That's really very encouraging for my future inference bills being substantially lower.
我还没去攻克矩阵乘法和向量加的原因是，我觉得它们并不是特别有趣的问题，因为对于这两者来说，光速极限（speed of light）的答案将是非常明确的。不过我不知道。也许我在这方面会猜错。天哪，我对那个排序的结果非常满意！因为那个排序，是用 Deep Seek V4 运行的。所以这是我第一次从 Deep Seek V4 Pro 获得非常好的结果。我对此非常高兴。这确实极大地鼓舞了我，让我看到未来推理成本会大幅降低。
Six out of eight. You only got two to go. Yeah. So we couldn't do it, folks. do it. We tried to talk about not AI, but we ended up talking about it. Yeah. I don't, what was I even saying? For years time. I don't know. Something about parenting. I don't know. When I'm editing this before, I'll realize that I was mid-thought, and unfortunately, the listener will never get to know the end of it. I mean, what else has happened? You said you were at some conference, the singularity conference? Yeah, I was at that. I was at Go-Sim. I was the one in Paris, right? Yeah, yeah. Do you
六分之六（应为六分之八）。你还差两个。是的。所以我们做不到，各位。我们做不到。我们试图聊点不谈 AI 的话题，但结果还是聊到了这上面。是的。我不知道，我刚才在说什么来着？四年的时间。我不知道。大概是关于育儿的事吧。我不知道。当我之前在剪辑的时候，我会意识到我当时正在思考中，但不幸的是，听众永远不会知道结局了。我的意思是，还发生了什么？你说你在哪个会议上，奇点大会？对，我去了那个。我去参加了 Go-Sim。就是帕里斯（Paris）那个，对吧？对，对。你……
of their conferences coming up. Do we have programming language stuff to talk about? Programming languages. I don't know that I care about programming languages anymore, Connor. Honestly. I don't know that I care about programming languages. All right. Maybe that's what the title of this episode will be.
他们的会议就要到了。我们有编程语言相关的内容要聊吗？编程语言。Connor，我不知道我是否还在乎编程语言。说实话。我不知道我是否还在乎编程语言。好吧。也许这就是这期节目的标题了。
Programming languages, do they matter? Or like, do programming languages matter anymore? Question mark. Go, Bryce. Talk for 20 minutes and round this episode out. I mean, yeah, I'm sure they're still matter. I do think they still matter and are still important. But like agentic engineering just feels like a higher priority thing for me right now.
编程语言，它们还重要吗？或者说，编程语言还重要吗？问号。上吧，Bryce。讲 20 分钟，为这期节目收个尾。我的意思是，是的，我确信它们依然重要。我的确认为它们依然重要，并且依然很重要。但智能工程对我来说感觉是个更高优先级的事情。
Because, like, again, my mandate and mission is how do people program parallel platforms, specifically in Viti's parallel platform? But sort of my whole career has been around that. And like, that comes down to like, how do people get performance out of a platform? and this is like a whole new field of agentic engineering and and you know people have been doing programming languages for a long time. It's a lot more matured and I feel like there's a lot more to learn and discover here in the world of agentic engineering and like how agentic engineering impacts our programming languages, our compilers, our tooling. Like that, that I'm very interested in, you know. I don't have answers yet for how agentic engineering impacts programming language.
因为，再次说明，我的职责和使命是人们如何对并行平台进行编程，特别是英伟达的并行平台？我的整个职业生涯基本上都是围绕这个展开的。这归根结底在于人们如何从平台中榨取性能。而这就像是智能工程的一个全新领域，而且你知道的，人们研究编程语言已经很久了。它要成熟得多，我觉得在智能工程的世界里，还有很多东西需要去学习和探索，比如智能工程将如何影响我们的编程语言、编译器和工具链。类似于这些，我是非常感兴趣的，你知道的。对于智能工程将如何影响编程语言，我还没有答案。
languages. I think I'm starting to see how it will impact, you know, tools, compilers, et cetera. But I don't yet know how it impacts programming languages. Yeah. I mean, I think the one thing I will, I will posit here, and we, you and I talked about this in the past is I think there is this question of whether higher level abstractions are more token token efficient to reach good performance than lower level abstractions. If you're using something like Parrot or Kutile or Triton, can you write good performance code at a significantly lower token cost? And then can you port that code to a new architecture at a significantly lower token cost?
语言。我想我开始看到它将如何影响工具、编译器等等。但我还不知道它将如何影响编程语言。是的。我的意思是，我想我要在这里提出一个观点，你和我过去也讨论过这个问题，那就是：是否存在这样一个问题——为了达到良好的性能，更高层次的抽象是否比低层次的抽象具有更高的 Token 效率？如果你使用的是像 Parakeet、cuTENSORL 或 Triton 这样的工具，你是否能以明显较低的 Token 成本编写出高性能代码？然后你是否能以明显较低的 Token 成本将该代码移植到新的架构上？
And I think there's a lot of people believe that to be the case. I have not seen a comprehensive study published evaluating this. And I think it'd be great work for someone to do. And you could look at it, you could look at things like all these DSLs that popped up, but you could even just evaluate it solely on programming languages. Like, I think it might be sufficient to look at like, you know, trying to write like some, some code with like C++, C, Python, and Fortran. And, you know, my guess is that, like, a language like Fortran, which has slightly, like,
我认为很多人都相信事实确实如此。我还没有看到发表的综合研究来评估这一点。我认为如果有人能做这项工作会很棒。你可以看看它，你可以看看诸如所有这些涌现出来的 DSL（领域特定语言），但你甚至可以仅仅从编程语言的角度来评估它。比如，我认为仅仅尝试用 C++、C、Python 和 Fortran 编写一些代码可能就足够了。而且，我猜想，像 Fortran 这样稍微具有……
higher level abstractions and you don't have to, for stuff like numerical code, you don't have to do as much low-level tweaking, but it still gets very good performance. Like, it might show very favorably there. So it'd be nice if somebody had, like, an E-L-L-L-E-L. suite or a benchmark to do these sorts of evaluations. There probably is something out there like this. I just don't know about it. But those are the sorts of questions that I think are interesting is like how token efficient is our existing languages. Because I don't think we have enough information yet to know how we should evolve programming languages to be more token efficient and agent friendly. And I do think
更高层次抽象的语言，并且对于数值代码之类的内容，你不需要做那么多的底层调整，但它仍然能获得非常好的性能。它在那方面可能会表现得非常有利。所以，如果有人能拥有一个 LLLLL 套件或基准测试来做这类评估就好了。外面可能确实有类似的东西。我只是不知道罢了。但这些是我认为有趣的问题，比如我们现有的语言的 Token 效率有多高。因为我认为我们还没有足够的信息来了解我们应该如何将编程语言演进得对 Token 更高效、对 Agent 更友好。而且我确实认为
the two are linked together. I think that like if you if you optimize your thing for token efficiency, you are implicitly making it more agent-friendly. Because what's the most token inefficient thing? Well, if the agent uses your thing and gets a compilation error or gets a tool failure because it was unclear how to use your thing or there were ambiguities or your thing was hard to use, well, that's going to waste a bunch of tokens. So if you just minimize token usage, if that's just your objective function, then you'll make your thing more agent-friendly. we should just put a loop around that put a loop around that
这两者是联系在一起的。我认为，如果你为了 Token 效率而优化你的东西，你实际上就是在隐式地让它对 Agent 更友好。因为什么东西的 Token 效率最低？如果你编写的东西，让 Agent 在使用时遇到了编译错误，或者因为使用方法不明、存在歧义或者你的东西很难用而导致工具失败，好吧，那就会浪费一堆 Token。因此，如果你只是尽量减少 Token 的使用，如果这就是你的目标函数，那么你就会让你的东西对 Agent 更友好。我们应该围绕它建立一个循环，围绕它建立一个循环。
yeah just like okay that's that's going to be my new answer for anybody who tells me how do I make my thing more agent friendly I'm just going to say make some eval that uses your thing and then just put an agenic loop around it that's minimizing
是的，就像——好吧，这将是我对任何问我“如何让我的东西对 Agent 更友好”的人的新回答。我只会说：写一个使用你的东西的评测（eval），然后围绕它放一个智能体循环（agentic loop），使其最小化。
that subjective function is minimize the number of tokens to achieve this task yeah I guess you got to isolate though to make sure that like each time you're launching your like prompts like you're going to run into like cashing and you know context bleeding that could like affect things right i don't think across session you have to worry about cashing yeah okay maybe if you don't
这个目标函数就是最小化完成任务所需的 Token 数量。是的，我想你必须进行隔离，以确保每次启动提示词（prompt）时，你都会遇到缓存和上下文污染（context bleeding）的问题，这可能会影响到事情，对吧？我不认为跨会话你需要担心缓存。是的，好吧，也许你不需要担心这个。我很确定会话会被隔离。是的，我很确定，我很确定。我的意思是，我可能在这方面搞错了，但我相当确信会话是隔离的。如果没有，我相信肯定有办法进行隔离。我们甚至没有聊到 Rust。所以 Rust 将是另一个要扔进竞技场的语言，因为 Rust 上有很多护栏。所以它在编译时就能捕获很多错误，因为它拥有这种通过构建确保正确的模型。所以有趣的评测会是：好吧，如果你给 Agent 一个相同的任务，并要求它分别用 Rust 和 C++ 来完成，它完成它所消耗的 Token 会更少吗？因为在 Rust 中，写出糟糕的代码要困难得多。
have to worry about that i'm pretty sure sessions will be isolated yeah i'm pretty sure i'm pretty sure i mean i could be wrong about that but i'm pretty sure the sessions are isolated if not i'm sure there's a way that you can't isolate. We didn't even talk about Rust. So Rust would be the other language to throw in the gauntlet there because Rust has a lot of guardrails on it. So it catches a lot of like errors at compile time because it has this current Rect by construction model. So like the interesting Eval would be like, okay, if you give an agent the same task and ask you do it in Rust versus C+++, does it complete it in fewer tokens? because in Rust, it's just harder to write bad code.
答案很可能是的。再说一次，我只是没有——我没有看到能证明这一点的研究摆在眼前。是的。你在搞研究。你应该去干这个。已经有足够多的人在搞 Rust 了，而且老实说……不，不，不，但这与 Rust 无关。
The answer's probably. Again, I just haven't, like, I haven't seen the study in front of me proving that. Yeah. You work in research. You should go do that. There's already enough people working on Rust, and to be honest... No, no, no, but it's not about Rust.
我想说的是，应该有人去评估编程语言的 Agent 就绪度（agent readiness）。我的意思是，这与我正在从事的一些工作有相似之处。我更多地致力于抽象层级，即你所针对的层级。这和你说 Fortran 对比 C++ 对比 Python 没什么不同。但我更倾向于认为，你甚至可以在单一语言内部做到这一点，比如，一些高级的东西比如 Parakeet，然后是 Thrust、CUB，然后一直到生写的 CUDA C++。是的，是的。或者总体来说，如果有什么……我认为这是一个非常有趣的观点，也许我在这里把抽象层级和编程语言混为一谈了。
It's what I'm saying is somebody should evaluate the agent readiness of programming languages. I mean, that's adjacent to kind of some of the... stuff that I'm working on. I'm working on more of like the abstraction layer, like level that you're targeting. Like not dissimilar to when you said Fortran versus, you know, C++ versus Python. But my more thing is like you could even do the same thing within a single language, right? Like, you know, some high level thing like parrot, then thrust, then cub, then just rock coot of C++. Yeah, yeah. Or just in general, like, yeah, like if something... And I think that's a really interesting point that maybe I'm conflating abstraction level with programming language here.
我认为抽象层级部分比编程语言的具体细节更重要的问题。我的意思是，也许它们在某种程度上是正交的，但我真正想问的是抽象层级。问题是，在任何语言中，虽然我对 Fortran 不是很熟悉，但就像即使在 Python 中，你也可以掀开汽车引擎盖，开始用 Python 内部的 C API 做一些疯狂的事情。我最关心的是，如果你针对这些层中的哪一层，会带来最好的结果。我当然有我自己的个人理论。但这就是方向。你刚才说的话，让我不禁在想，是的，我不知道。你认为从现在起五、十年后会怎样？
I do think that the abstraction level part is the more important question than the specifics of a programming language. I mean, maybe they are to some degree orthogonal, but what I was really asking about was abstraction level. And the thing is, in any language, like, I'm not too familiar with Fortran, but like even Python, you can, like, you know, open up the hood of the car and start doing some crazy stuff with basically, like, see APIs within Python. And my main thing is like which one of these layers if you're targeting is going to result in like the best outcomes. And I have my own personal theories. But that's, yeah, that's the direction. It just, what you were saying, though, makes me just think, yeah, like, I don't know. Where do you, where do you think like five years, ten years from now?
这一切将走向何方？我听过对 Boris Churney 的一次采访。有人问他，当我们进入后 AGI 时代会发生什么？我不会说出他的答案，但……总会有——总会有 AI 医生的。我们总是需要 AI 医生。这就是你的看法。是的。
Where does this all end? Like, I listened to an interview with Boris Churney. And it was, he got asked, you know, what happens when we're post-AGI? And I won't, I won't say his answer, but. There's always, there's always going to be AI doctors. We're always going to need AI doctors. That's what you think it is. Yeah.
不，我的意思是，如果我们思考当今模型的状态，我可以想象会发生几种不同的范式转变。其一是将更多的思考和推理转移到模型内部的潜空间（latent space）中发生。据我所知，目前大多数推理的工作原理是：模型生成一个输出，然后将其作为输入重新吸纳进去，而不是这一切都在潜空间中发生。所以你会听到很多关于循环 Transformer（looped transformers）的想法，人们声称 Mythos 可能就是那样的东西。但是，我认为这是一个很可能会发生的大范式转变，会对产生重大影响。这不是我预期会对智能工程部分产生太大影响的事情。
Yeah. No, I mean, I think if we think about the state of models today, there's a couple different paradigm shifts that I can imagine happening. One is moving more of thinking and reasoning to happen in the latent space within the model itself. My understanding is that today most of the reasoning works by model generates an output and then takes that back in as an input instead of this all happening within the latent space. So you hear a lot about the idea of looped transformers and people claiming that maybe mythos is that. But, like, I think that is a thing that is, you know, likely to be a big paradigm shift that'll have big impacts. It's not as, not something I would expect to impact the agentic engineering part too much.
尽管如此，如果推理发生在潜空间内，那么它对我们的可见度就会比今天要低。我的意思是，你所看到的那些被称为思考轨迹（thinking traces）或推理轨迹的东西，其实已经有点像是一个谎言了，因为它们并不是真正的推理轨迹，也不是真正的内部过程。它只是模型为你生成它对内部过程应该是怎样的看法罢了。无论如何，另一件事是关于记忆的。
Although, if the reasoning happens within the latent space, then it's going to be less visible to us than it is today. I mean, it's already probable, the thing that you see that's, that are called, like, thinking traces or reasoning traces are already, like, kind of a lie because it's, It's not really the reasoning trace, it's not really like the internal process. It's just sort of like the model, like generating for you its idea of what the internal process would be. Anyways, the other thing is around like memory.
所以现在有很多关于记忆的各种系统，其中很多归根结底就是：我们在某处有一些 Markdown 文件。我认为，对于更一流的记忆系统，对于让长期记忆成为 LLM 更一流的一部分，还有很大的发展空间。但这里也有一个工程问题，那就是你如何管理和构建具有这种自我演化记忆的可靠系统？我正在运行的几乎所有智能体工作负载都在临时虚拟机（ephemeral VMs）上运行。
So there's all these various systems from memory today, a lot of which kind of boil down to like, we have some series of markdown files somewhere. And I think that there's like a lot of room for more first class memory systems, for memory, longer term memory of being more of a first class part of the LLN. But there's an engineering problem here too, which is how do you, like, manage and build reliable systems that have this self-evolving memory? So almost all of the agenic workflows that I'm doing are running on ephemeral VMs.
所以智能体可能会运行两三天、四天甚至一周，但之后我会关闭这些虚拟机。因此，我从中学到的任何信息、学习成果或任何东西，我都会放进技能（skills）中。我会把它放进我的工具包、工具等里面。我不会运行……你知道的，我来自 HPC（高性能计算）世界。我从不在笔记本电脑上运行东西。我有一台用了 10 年的笔记本电脑，因为我的笔记本电脑只是一个瘦客户端（thin client）。从我职业生涯开始，我就从不在笔记本电脑上运行任何东西。我的笔记本电脑只是连接到某个地方的某个节点的 SSH 终端。
So the agent might run for two or three or four days or even a week, but then like I'm going to shut down that VMs. So any like information or learning or anything that I take out of that, I'm going to put into skills. I'm going to put into my harness, my tools, et cetera. I'm not running like, you know, I come from the HPC world. I never run stuff on my laptop. I have like a 10-year-old laptop because my laptop's just a thin client because start of my career, I never ran anything on my laptop anyways. My laptop is just an SSH terminal to some node somewhere.
因此，与其他开发者相比，我一直有一种截然不同的思维方式。我从来都不是那种在本地构建东西的人。我总是在云端的某个地方进行。所以我从来不在笔记本电脑上在本地运行智能体。这意味着我一直不得不思考：什么数据需要被持久化？我认为很多人最后往往会构建这样一个智能体：它随着时间的推移具有个性，拥有记忆、长期记忆等，拥有所有这些能够让用户定制它的东西。对我来说，这方面的成分要少得多，因为我做的任何类似的事情，
And so I've always sort of had a very different mindset than other developers. is I've never been somebody who's built stuff locally. I'm always doing it somewhere in the cloud. And so I'm never running an agent locally on my laptop. And that means that I've always had to think about, you know, what data needs to be persisted. I think a lot of people end up, you know, sort of building like an agent that has a personality over time that has memories, longer term memories, etc., that has, you know, all of these things that sort of allow them to customize it. For me, I have a lot less of that because anything I do like that,
我都必须将其嵌入到我的技能或配置中。但是，未来显而易见的是，那些随着时间推移了解并学习你的智能体将是最有用的东西。我认识到了这一点。我今天不一定在用它，但是那些拥有自己的记忆系统的东西，将是最有用的东西。
I need to, like, embed into my skills or my config. But, like, in the future, obviously, you know, agents that know and learn about you over time are going to be the most useful thing. Like, I recognize that. I'm not necessarily using that today, but, like, things that have their own, like, memory system, those are going to be the most useful things.
但是，我们该如何确保一个已经运行了六个月或一年、并建立起这种复杂记忆系统的智能体——我们如何确保它是可靠且可复现的，当出问题时你该如何调试它？这看起来像是未来一个真正的挑战。我认为我们正越来越走向这样一个世界：这些智能体将是永远在线、永远运行的。
But how are we going to, like, ensure that an agent that's been like running for six months or a year and has this like complex memory system that it's built up like how are we going to ensure that that's like reliable and reproducible and like how are you going to debug that when something goes wrong? That seems like that seems like a real challenge in the future. I think we're moving more and more towards a world of like these like always on, always running agents.
也许在未来，我们甚至会拥有基本上本质上一直在思考或推理的智能体。你知道的，我的意思是，我不知道，也许我们今天就已经达到了。其中许多循环往往正在从推理走向等待，再走向进行工具调用。但也许，AGI 意味着这样一个系统：它基本上一直在思考。我只是觉得，让这些东西保持连贯将会非常有趣。而且，从运行几天到几周的任务，过渡到运行几个月到几年的任务或智能体，将是一个非常棘手的问题。部分原因在于：我们该如何模拟和测试一个运行数月甚至数年的智能体？
Maybe in the future we'll even have agents that are basically like essentially always like reasoning or inferring. You know, I mean, I don't know, maybe we're there already today. A lot of these loops tend to be moving from, like, you know, inference to sort of like waiting to, like, doing tool calls. But maybe, like, AGI means, like, a system where it's basically, like, always thinking. And I just, I think it's going to be very interesting to make those things coherent. And I think going from tasks that run for days to weeks to tasks or agents that, like, run for, like, months to years is going to be a very hard problem. in part because, like, how do we simulate and test an agent that runs for, like, months to years?
我不知道。这看起来很有挑战性。这可能标志着软件领域可靠性的终结。是的，我总是想起这样一个事实：如果你回想 30 年前，你知道的，互联网才刚刚起步。而现在我们所有人都随身携带超级计算机，巴拉巴拉，还有社交网络，仅仅在 30 年内，技术格局就发生了如此巨大的变化，以至于根本无法预测 30 年后的情况。
I don't know. That seems challenging. This may be the end of, like, reliability in the software space. Yeah, I always think about, you know, the fact that if you think about 30 years ago, you know, the internet is just, like, beginning. And now where we all, like, carry supercomputers and blah, blah, blah, and there's social, networks and just like in 30 years the technology landscape has changed so much that it's like impossible to be able to predict like 30 years from now.
但我确实想到了《钢铁侠》第一部里的那个场景，他正在用全息投影建造他的战衣，他把所有的部件炸开，然后抓起一个部件并扭转它，巴拉巴拉。我想到了将这一点应用于机械可解释性（mechanistic interpretability），它将成为机械可解释性的一种视觉版本，你可以进入某种——你知道的，三维全息图，戴上某种苹果 Vision Pro 的未来版本，然后你就可以进去查看由某个 AI 系统构建的三维知识图谱的某种版本，并且将有一种方法
But I do think about like the Iron Man scene and the first Iron Man that came out where he's like building his suit with like a holographic projection where he's like exploding out all the pieces and then grabbing a piece and twisting it and blah blah. And I think about that applied to like. mechanistic and interpretability where it's going to be like visual like a visual version of like mechanistic interp where you get to go into some like you know 3D holographic you're going to put on some you know futuristic version of the apple vision pro and then you're going to be able to go in and look at some version of a three-dimensional knowledge graph that some AI system is built and like there will be a way
来解释它的知识库或知识花园，随你怎么称呼它。那将是酷毙了。并且我认为，那可能成为未来编程的一种形式！如果你有这样一个系统，它正在一堆 CUDA kernel 或无论你的什么东西上进行爬山算法（hill climbing），然后你就可以进去，并想出不同改进方式和它找到路径的视觉表现。比如——你看过卡帕西（Karpathy）几个月前关于知识库和构建知识库的内容吗？没有。是一个演讲还是？
to interpret like its knowledge store or knowledge garden or whatever you want to call it. And that is going to be so freaking cool. And like that, I think that, like, that could be a form of programming in the future, right? Like if you've got some system that's hill climbing on a bunch of, whether it's Kuda kernels or whatever your thing is, and then you can go in and come up with a visual, like, representation of the different improvements and ways that it found its way. Like, like, have you seen the Carpathies thing about, like, knowledge bases and building knowledge bases from a couple months ago? No. Is it a talk or?
我不知道。可能是一条推文。我所有的信息都来自推特上关于人工智能进展的动态。但我觉得非常相似。这就是这样一种想法：也许下一步是如何让智能体编译和编排知识？就像今天许多技能的创建在很大程度上仍然是由人类驱动的一样，技能的创建和组织也是如此。我们创建和组织技能的规模是人类可以进去查看和复审的。也许在未来，我们会拥有由模型策划和准备的知识库。也许它们可供人类查看，但同时也是模型可用于未来工作的知识基础。是的。我只是，我不知道。我不知道怎么说。我明白存在各种担忧等等，但我只是太兴奋了。我的意思是，还有一件事，另一件事刚刚闯入我的脑海：我曾经在跟肖恩·帕伦特（Sean Parent）谈论她的名字。
I don't know. It may have been a tweet. I get all my information tweets on what's going on in AI. But I think it was very similar. It's this idea of like, you know, maybe the next step is like how do we how do we have agents like compile and orchestrate like knowledge? Like a lot of like creation of like, like, today a lot of like creation of skills is still largely like driven by like humans and like the creation and organization of skills. And we create and organize skills like of a scale that like humans can go in like look and review through. And maybe in the future we have these like knowledge bases that are like curated and prepared by models. Maybe that are viewable for humans, but also that are, you know, these basis of knowledge that the models can use for their future work. Yeah. It's just, I don't know. I don't know how. I understand there's concerns, et cetera, but I just, I'm so excited. Like, I mean, there's another, there's another thing that just popped into my head is I, at one point when we were talking to Sean Parent about her name.
名字是，我想是杰西（Jesse），让我现在查一下。还是特里（Terry）？实际上，我把这当作潜在的未来嘉宾。如果我访问 ADSP 并往下滚动，它会写着杰里（Jerry）。所以我刚才说什么了？我说了杰西
name was, I think Jesse, let me look it up right now. Or is it Terry? Actually, I have this as a potential future guest. If I just go to ADSP and I scroll down, it will say Jerry. So what did I say? I said Jesse
然后是特里。她就是杰里·埃尔斯沃思（Jerry Ellsworth），她是那种全息风格桌游工具背后的那个人。我知道，甚至早在某些 CppCast 的剧集中，他们就谈到了《龙与地下城》以及它的增强现实版本。
and then Terry. It is Jerry Ellsworth and she's the individual behind a holographic-esque kind of board game tool. And I know even as far back on some CPPCast episode, So they were talking about like Dungeons and Dragons and, like, augmented reality version of that.
但就像今天一个现实世界的例子一样，Shima 和我，我们非常喜欢这款游戏——《展翅翱翔》（Wingspan）。我们都是观鸟爱好者。我们喜欢桌游。《展翅翱翔》是一款鸟类游戏。我也玩过这款游戏。是的，这是一款带有鸟类风味的游戏。其实是和 Olivier 还有他的孩子们一起玩的。很有趣。
But like, literally like a real world example today is Shima and I, we love this game, Wingspan. We're both birders. We like board games. Wingspan is a bird. I, too, have played this game. Yeah, it's a bird-flavored game. With Olivier and his kids actually. Interesting.
是的，这是一款很棒的游戏。我有很多扩展包。但有时它非常注重记分。需要大约五分钟的准备时间来设置。而且由于组件太多，比如鸟蛋等、食物。跟踪所有这些东西有点烦人，而且可以保证每两局游戏中就会有一局，我们两个中会有一个人的回合方块数量
Yeah, it's a great game. I have a bunch of the expansions. But sometimes it's a very point-sality. Requires like five minutes of prep to set up. And because there's so many components, eggs, et cetera, food. It's a little bit irritating to, like, keep track of everything and, like, guaranteed one out of every two games, like, we, one of us doesn't have, like, the number of turn
没排在正确的顺序上，我们得弄清楚到底是谁没有把回合方块放在正确的地方。我们在 boardgame arena.com 上也会玩，有时会在那里玩，但没有扩展包。有时如果我们只是——我们没有精力去摆弄实体桌游，尽管我们更喜欢那样做，我们就会去玩线上版。她会来我的办公室，在她的笔记本电脑上玩，我在我的电脑上玩。我很想要一个基本上是两者结合的版本：既有扩展包，同时又有增强现实（AR）版本，或者更好的是，就像《星球大战》里的怪物格斗游戏那样。
cubes, like, in the right order, and we have to figure out who, who didn't put a turn cube in the right place. We also, on boardgame arena.com, play there sometimes, but it's without the expansions. And sometimes if we just, we don't have the energy to set up the physical board game, even though we prefer doing that, we'll just go and we'll play. she'll come to my office she'll plan her laptop i'll play on my computer and i would love a basically like combination of the two where you have the expansions but then also like have the augmented reality version or even better like it's it's like the star wars you know monster fighting game
他们总是在桌子上玩，并且有全息怪物。我甚至不想戴上增强现实眼镜，只要在你的餐桌角落或其他你玩游戏的地方放几个小盘子，然后——嘭，你就有了一个全息版本。所以你仍然以玩桌游的最佳方式进行面对面的游戏。但你不需要做所有的记分、总分计算以及移动鸟蛋的工作。哦，你真的支付了玩第四只鸟时所需的两枚鸟蛋了吗？
where they always play at the table and they've got the holographic monsters i would love to not even be able to have to put on augmented reality glasses and just have some like little you know discs that you put at the corner of your your dining table or wherever you're playing and poof, you've got the holographic version. So you're still playing in person the best way to do board games. But you don't need to do all of the point tracking and the point totaling and the moving of eggs. And oh, did you actually pay the two eggs that you were required to play in order to play, you know, the king rail as your fourth bird in your wetland?
而且，这怎么能不……你知道的，有些人可能会觉得：“哦，你们在毁掉它。拥有科技感觉很好。”是的，有很多人会对这些话感到非常沮丧。是的，但我的意思是，那将会太棒了。而且，在 boardgame arena 的数字版上，你可以使用几个不同的设置，因为有几只鸟被称为 OP 鸟。对于不懂行的人来说，OP 的意思是 OP（过强，Overpowered）。两只渡鸦、杀嘴鸟（Killdeer）、富兰克林鸥（Franklin's gull），然后是林鸭（wood duck）被认为是……林鸭有点像 T2（二级）OP 鸟。
And like, how that wouldn't, and, you know, some people probably are being like, oh, you're ruining. Like, it's nice to have a tech. Yeah, you're, there's so many, there's so many people who are going to be so upset at the words. Yeah, but like, I'm just like saying that that would be amazing. And, and also, too, like on the digital version on board game arena, you can play with a couple different settings because there's a few birds that are known as the O.P. O.P. for those that don't know the lingo is overpowered. And the two Ravens, the kill deer, Franklin's goal, and then the wood duck are considered. The wood duck's kind of like a tier two opi bird.
但当你玩竞技模式时（我从不玩，但你可以参加锦标赛之类的），他们会把这些鸟移除，因为当人们抽到它们时，它们被认为是不公平的优势。你可以想象，哦，我们可以玩一个不同的版本。你可以跟某个模型对话并说：“其实，我们可以玩这个游戏的变体吗？”然后你只需解释规则的改变。它就会将其整合进去。你可以搞出一个不同版本的《拼字游戏》（Scrabble）、不同版本的国际象棋或跳棋。或者，你知道的，也许你在和你的孩子玩，你想给自己加个让子（handicap）。这个词对吗？我可以说这个词吗？好吧，随便啦。
But you can, when you're playing competitive, which I never do, but you can enter tournaments and stuff, they remove those birds because they're, considered such an unfair advantage when you get them. And like, you can imagine like, oh, like, let's play like a different version. You can like, you'll be able to talk to some model and say, we're actually, can we play a variant of this game? And you just explain the rule change. And then it'll incorporate it. And you can like, you're going to come up with a different version of Scrabble and a different version of chess or checkers. Or like, you know, maybe you're playing with your kid and you want to have like a, you know, a handicap. Is that the right? Am I allowed to say that? All right, whatever.
但是当你在打竞技模式时，虽然我从不玩竞技，但你可以参加锦标赛之类的，他们会把那些鸟移除，因为当你得到它们时，它们被认为是不公平的优势。而且就像你可以想象的那样，哦，比如，让我们玩一个不同的版本。你可以，你将能够和某种模型对话并说，实际上，我们能玩这个游戏的变体吗？然后你只要解释规则的改变。接着它就会整合进去。你就可以，你将会创造出不同版本的《拼词游戏》以及不同版本的国际象棋或西洋跳棋。或者就像，你知道的，也许你在和你的孩子玩，你想设置一个，你知道的，让步。这是对的吗？我能这么说吗？好吧，随便吧。
Well, I apologize. If that's the wrong term to say in 2026. I don't think that that's the right term. Whatever the right term is, I don't mean to be offensive. But like, if you want to make it so that it's more competitive when you're playing with your kid in the future, and so you put some, you know, head start. You give your kid a head start or you double the points, you know, that your kid is getting. And then, you know, you can even, you could even, I was just thinking, well, isn't it valuable for your kid to be adding up the scores and,
好吧，我道歉。如果这是2026年不应该说的词的话。我不认为那是正确的词。不管正确的词是什么，我无意冒犯。但就像，如果你想让你以后和孩子一起玩游戏时更具竞争力，所以你加了一些，你知道的，领先优势。你给你的孩子一个领先优势，或者把你知道的你孩子获得的分数翻倍。然后，你知道的，你甚至可以，我刚才在想，对你的孩子来说，自己去加分数，
and doing the math, him or herself. And it's like, well, you talk to the modeling. You say, you know what? We'd actually like to score ourselves. So give him a little scratch pad where he can draw it with his finger and do the 10 plus 12. But if he ever makes a mistake or she makes a mistake, give a little like corrective thing and say, oh, you know, you made a classic mistake. You didn't carry the one. Blah, blah, blah.
然后自己做数学题，难道不是很有价值吗？就像，你可以和模型对话。你说，你知道吗？我们其实想自己计分。所以给他一个小写字板，他可以用手指在上面画画，做10加12。但如果他犯了错误，或者她犯了错误，给一个小小的纠正，说，哦，你知道，你犯了一个经典的错误。你进位忘了一。诸如此类。
Amazing. Amazing. Look at you. I just like, I'm spitting off ideas here. This is, this is gold here. You know, I should start an augmented reality. board game. Well, you've just broadcast the idea to all your listeners. But if you want to invest in Conner's idea. The thing is I'm sure there's like 14 different companies, including Jerry, I know,
太棒了。太棒了。看看你。我只是，我在这里抛出各种想法。这，这真是黄金创意。你知道的，我应该创办一家增强现实棋盘游戏公司。好吧，你刚刚把这个想法广播给了你所有的听众。但如果你想投资康纳的想法。问题是，我确信有大概14家不同的公司，包括杰里，我知道，
was working on stuff like this. But like, I don't really have the energy or the time to do any of this stuff because I'm happy at Nvidia doing the work that I'm doing. But I just, I can't wait until this stuff comes out because it's guaranteed it's going to exist in the next 30 years or something like this. It is like the last six months have been probably my best. some of my best times at Nvidia. And like, yeah, this stuff is just so exciting and fun. Yeah. I don't think I've been quite so excited about the day-to-day engineering tasks
以前在做类似的事情。但就像，我真的没有精力或时间去做这些事情，因为我在英伟达做现在的工作很开心。但我只是，我等不及这些东西面世了，因为可以肯定的是，在未来30年左右它一定会存在。就像过去六个月可能是我在英伟达最好的时光之一。而且，是的，这些东西太令人兴奋和有趣了。是的。自我职业生涯开始以来，
since the start of my career. Yeah. And like, you know, I'm sure there's some people that are thinking, blah, blah, blah, blah, terrible for the world. It's not all terrible, folks. I have become a lawn, what do you call? A lawn enthusiast, you know? My Kentucky Blue Graveller.
我好像还没有对日常的工程任务感到如此兴奋。是的。而且，你知道，我确信有些人会想，巴拉巴拉，对世界太糟糕了。并非一切都很糟糕，各位。我已经成了一个草坪，你叫什么？草坪爱好者，你知道吗？我的肯塔基早熟禾。
grass, grass, front and backyard. How do I know that? Thanks to AI. You just send it photos and you say, listen, grade my lawn. I got a D-plus. We got lots of creeping Charlie. We got lots of clover. And my wife and I are environmentally conscious, so we're not using any pesticides.
草，草，前院和后院。我是怎么知道的？多亏了人工智能。你只需要给它发照片然后说，听着，给我的草坪打分。我得了D加。我们有很多长蔓假地黄。我们有很多三叶草。我和我妻子都有环保意识，所以我们不使用任何杀虫剂。
It's going to be a lot more work. We got to use the... This is the Connor equivalent of Bryce's couch stuff. Yeah, well, yeah. I mean, everyone, yeah, maybe you're going to be the furniture guy and I'm going to be the lawn care guy. Because honestly, I remember my dad. My dad built a table. from some wood planks that lived on my grandfather and my grandmother's farm in Terrace, BC.
这要麻烦得多。我们得用……这是布赖斯的沙发梗的康纳版。是的，好吧，是的。我的意思是，每个人，是的，也许你要成为家具专家，而我要成为草坪护理专家。因为老实说，我记得我爸爸。我爸爸用我爷爷奶奶在BC省特雷斯农场的木板，做了一张桌子。
Rest in peace to both of them. But they had a wonderful farm and they had these wood planks. My dad took them. We drove him eight hours to Prince George where I grew up. He built this, like, beautiful table. And, like, he spent so many weeks slash months. And every single time he would sit down, he would, like, rub his hand on it to, like, look at, like, the quality. Was it smooth enough?
愿他们两个安息。但他们有一个很棒的农场，这些木板就在那里。我爸爸拿了它们。我们开车八小时把它运到我长大的乔治王子城。他建了这张，呃，漂亮的桌子。而且，他花了好几个星期甚至几个月。每次他坐下来，他都会，呃，用手去摸它，来检查，比如，质量。它够光滑吗？
That we need to put, like, another layer of liqueur or whatever they call it on, a lacquer? and we would all, me and my three sisters would always make fun of them, like, because he's always, like, we'd sit down to eat and what is he doing? He's, ah, you know, this table, you know, maybe got to do some stuff. I have now become my father because every day I basically walk out, especially if it's rained, and I am like assessing, you know, oh, did the iron kill enough of the, uh, the creeping Charlie or the clover or whatever. And it is like, it brings me so much joy. And also, we have a skunk. We named him Wilbur. And we had to have a discussion, Chima and I about whether we were going to get.
我们是不是需要涂另一层清漆或者他们叫什么的东西，清漆？我和我的三个姐妹总是取笑他，因为他总是，呃，我们坐下来吃饭，他在干什么？他在，啊，你知道，这张桌子，你知道，也许得做点什么。我现在已经变成我父亲了，因为我每天基本上都会走出去，尤其是下雨的时候，我就像在评估，哦，铁剂有没有杀死足够的长蔓假地黄、三叶草或其他什么东西。这感觉，它给我带来了这么多的快乐。而且，我们有一只臭鼬。我们给它起名叫威尔伯。我和希玛不得不讨论一下我们是否要弄走
rid of the grubs that are living beneath our grass because it is the lunch buffet and dinner buffet for Wilbur the skunk who comes and just digs up these little holes and feeds himself and Shima said that she was very happy that our lawn was the skunk's lunch and dinner so we're just going to leave let Wilbur tear up the lawn but anyways I have to go around and like fill in these little holes that Wilbur keeps on digging in our front and back lawn and like all of this is thanks to AI I didn't care before and then And I was like, you know what, I bet AI could tell me how to like, you know, improve the quality of my lawn. And sure enough, it's... I'm going to buy you a chair so you can go yell at the kids and say, get off my lawn. No, no, no, no. The kids want to play on my lawn. They can play on my lawn.
草地底下的蛴螬，因为那是臭鼬威尔伯的午餐和晚餐自助餐，它会过来挖这些小洞自食其力。希玛说她很高兴我们的草坪是臭鼬的午餐和晚餐，所以我们打算不管它，让威尔伯把草坪弄得乱七八糟。但无论如何，我必须四处走动，把威尔伯一直挖的这些小洞填上，前草坪和后草坪都是如此。这一切都要归功于人工智能。我以前不在乎，然后我就想，你知道吗，我打赌人工智能能告诉我如何，你知道，提高草坪的质量。果不其然，它……我要给你买把椅子，这样你就可以去冲着孩子们大喊，从我的草坪上滚开。不，不，不，不。孩子们想在我的草坪上玩。他们可以在我的草坪上玩。
Anyways, the point is, it's not all bad, folks. If you, you know, give it a chance, it'll make you fall in love with your lawn as well. Be sure to check these show notes, either in your podcast app or at ADSP thepodcast.com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link. to a get-up discussion where you can leave thoughts, comments, and questions. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. Low quality, high quantity.
总之，重点是，并非一切都不好，各位。如果你，你知道的，给它一个机会，它也会让你爱上你的草坪。请务必查看节目笔记，无论是在您的播客应用程序中还是在 ADSP thepodcast.com 上，了解我们在今天的节目中提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个可以留下想法、评论和问题的 GitHub 讨论链接。感谢收听。希望您喜欢，祝您有美好的一天。低质量，高数量。
That is the tagline of our podcast. It's not the tagline. Our tagline is chaos with sprinkles of information. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这就是我们播客的标语。这不是标语。我们的标语是带有信息点缀的混乱。本期节目还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。